our next guest is a renowned drummer and
one of the most talented and beloved
musicians in the world and she just
released the new music video for the
salsa version of her original song by
lar
please welcome the queen of percussion
the one and only sheila e
[Applause]
oh my god in your eyeliner
[Applause]
okay
i am so excited you just broke a record
you and your dad pete escovedo
for being the first
father-daughter to win this award tell
us about it yeah we thank you
we were honored to receive the lifetime
achievement award from the latin grammys
and there's never been a father and
daughter to ever receive that
and then go cry no i cried like a baby
for like 20 minutes i couldn't get it
together i'd i was so happy for him
because to be acknowledged by
our peers and and he's just stuck to his
music this whole time when people kept
saying it would never work you know so
i'm happy for him i'm so
happy
that you could break a record with your
father who by the way i feel like we
have a lot in common because did you
grow up in nightclubs yes i did
i did my dad early on my mom had a job
and my dad being a musician he had went
to rehearsals and and he had he said i
was in one little basket and he would
put me on the counter at the club and
then the
bartender or the waitress would watch me
i'm like you left me with people like
but anyway he did what he had to do so i
grew up in the bars like that those were
good times yes they were it was a lot of
fun it really was a lot of fun
i watched your talk show thank you for
coming here thank you but you have a
talk show on youtube and really amazing
guests thank you yeah fred armisen and
mr copeland
i mean you there i was watching a few
episodes it's amazing thank you yeah i
had rango i just called ringo starr
yeah
yeah thank you
i you know i admired you so
much growing up i loved watching you
solo i loved watching you with prince i
loved watching you be a woman thank you
who
was there was nobody like you you
certainly carved out a
you know something all your own and
owned it yes yes i mean watching my dad
play every single day in the house he
played to vinyl to lp the records and
brought music in the house and then his
friends happened to be incredible
musicians and we lit growing up in the
bay area in oakland san francisco it's
just like everyone was from there carlos
santana grateful dead these people were
coming to our house and um we would be
able to jam with them and so i watched
my dad play even though i was training
to be in the olympics i was a track star
and then i played this one gig with my
dad at 15
and i just realized wait i think wait a
minute this is what i'm supposed to do
you know i had no idea how incredible it
was to play with my dad
at at 15 years old
and that show after we were done i told
my dad daddy daddy this is what i want
to do i want to be a musician he's like
no no
no are you kidding me and i was like no
but he knew it and then two weeks later
we went out on tour and i never looked
back that was it the beginning two weeks
later it's like you had something
bursting inside of you yeah and then it
was unleashed yeah and what was life
with prince like there's one story i
really like about how you fooled him
once so he had this party and he said
it's gonna be a costume party so
everyone's coming to the party and
whoever wins i think it was like five
thousand dollars of like oh i'm getting
that money right so i dressed up i had
my security guard he's like six
nine
and
i said you know what the only way for us
to win this is i'm going to have to put
some costume stuff on like i'm going to
dress up like a guy
so i it wasn't a guy really i was a pimp
and he was my home
right that's what i did and so i had my
makeup artist go and i got real hair and
we glued it and i asked for a mustache
and i put chest hair and i dressed like
a dude for real like and i said i was a
pimp i had a cane they they brought me a
suit a tie and it was incredible so we
walked around so he walked by me four
times he did not know it was me and then
finally i had to walk up to i said
prince and he just looked at me goes
and he just he was on literally laying
on the floor on his back laughing and i
got that money yes
[Music]